morning. So, I've got something a little
different for us
today. Um, the goal at the moment
is to try to get Puffer Lib up and
running on eight rented uh 800s or 800s
actually. Reason for this is that we're
getting new hardware delivered tomorrow
and uh we want to have our distributed
training set up. So I hate running
hardware in general. It's a pain. Uh but
I'm going to be trying some stuff out on
Hyperbolic cuz it seems kind of decent.
I just set this up recently earlier
today for a client. So yeah, we uh we're
going to take a look at what happens if
we can get eight
eight00s. You can see here I have this
single node. We're going to kill
this. And um let's actually make sure we
have DDP running before we rent one of
these because the goal is going to be
basically that we go
here network
volume. Uh this is interesting that it
uh it actually kind of just picks one
randomly. You can actually choose
here. They all look like uh
zeons until zeons. Fine. Yeah, we'll
just be end up like doing something like
this and like pick this and it'll be
like eight bucks an hour or whatever. I
forgot to to flip the screen over. I'm
dumb. Hello.
Welcome. Hey, captain. Mind giving box
to a full
reboot. Yes. All right.
Here. Okay, there you go. This will
what?
Oh, yeah. There you go. There's your
reboot. Uh, so yeah, for folks watching
this, I just
here. I'd forgotten to flip the screen
over. I'll go back through that stuff.
One
second. Chat. Put chat over here so I
don't miss it.
Let's check stick chat under camera.
Okay, so we have here uh hyperbolic 8x
800's ready to
go. Now all I got to do is make sure DDP
actually works.
on our latest stuff first.
anything. No such file or
directory. This is an old command.
That's
why GP wouldn't work because I set max
BPT size too high for
sweeps and triggered an
assertion. Currently has a hard max of
256 due to assertions. Cool. Yeah, I
need to clean up a bunch of stuff with
this.
um, my strategy was worked super hard on
Saturday to get like a bunch of new M
and demos things done, completely crash
out yesterday, get some RNR. Uh, I'm
pretty well rested and the goal is today
to start back on release side work. Uh,
so DDP is actually crucial for release.
That is one of the things that has to be
in there for clients specifically. Um,
it's also going to help us a lot And uh
surrounding like colonel shenanigans
will be included directly after.
DDP distributed data parallel. It's run
with our main algorithm. You're thinking
of
DDPG. What's this torch distributed to
run shenanigans
here? Buffer lib is not a
package. Should be
Ah, you know why? It's because
it's Can I do
Now, I don't think I actually had all
the initialization stuff set up for
this, but uh let's grab this
command. Put this over on the
side. Get a new window
8800 and I would like to put
uh
KudnN base on it.
Actually, this needs to
be need to edit this link.
Okay, so this is going to give us puffer
0 and uh we will see from
Here this
goes. The hope is that we should be able
to train at like 3 to four million steps
per second.
I don't know what CPUs these things have
though. We have to check
that. You'd hope that they'd at least
have like a 32 core processor, right?
It showed the specs on the website
popup, did
it? I don't see the
CPU. Oh, here it is. Yeah. So they
actually, you're right, they do show. So
it's Xenon. It looks like they've all
got Xenon,
links. Total core is
56. Okay.
So kind of an awkward number of cores
for
RL to not have
64. We can assume that we have four to
six
cores per per
core. Yes, it's like 500ishk on one
core. I mean one
GPU. We've got numbum nodes, num procs
per
right? Yes.
So if I do like
Well, it's a bit
suspicious. Also check our uh our local
settings.
this thing.
Yeah, this thing isn't doing anything.
It's just hanging, right?
So, I guess it's like waiting for an
init that I missed or
something. Okay. I know I had this
working in uh an earlier
build. Maybe even in
20. Did we have uh I don't know. Did we
have DDP in 20 at
It's not even getting to the
initialization
step. Figure out why that is.
There no way to search these
things. There should be a way to search
these. Yeah. And then like I didn't
squash commit.
thing. I believe the demo file had like
some sort of in it.
Yeah, this thing. So, did I miss this in
the port somehow?
rank. Okay. So we have this is
initialized.
Ah yeah this is what you wanted to have
in train
right but the thing is you've already
screwed up the
Where's the torch guide on this
thing? I forget if you even have to do
this manually anymore. If it just wraps
the policy for you.
Okay. No, you do have to do this
manually.
it cuz I think it's waiting to like
connect or whatever.
Oh, I see. It just doesn't work if you
have any sort of syntax error at all.
group. I see. So this actually has to
get called first.
and uh this rank should just be set to
rank, right?
Like no need for you to pass rank
manually. Just pass back end. Okay.
Lots of uh just changes to how we handle
our models, making it a little
tricky. Okay, so there we go. So that is
now training
with
hopefully what we expect.
logging. Uh, no, cuz I don't see
anything actually running at
all. So, we haven't even gotten to that
somehow.
trying to figure out where this thing
is.
So, it says to do this record
thing. This didn't do anything for uh
for me before.
Fine. I think it's not erroring. I think
it's just hanging, right?
Oh, cuz it's parsing none as a string.
That's super obnoxious.
crazy. I didn't know that I'd broken
that. That
sucks. Well, we can't fix that right
now.
So, it's weird that this works with one
node. Does it work with multiple
processes per
node? Let's
see. Okay, so this
works. Rocks per node should be
rank on both CUDA device. So, yeah. So,
this is not
uh Yeah, this thing that they gave us
doesn't make any bloody sense
because it the output
device like does this make sense?
Where's their Okay, they do have a
minimal example Here.
man. You know, it's like people use the
torch docks as a gold standard for
stuff, but they actually kind of suck if
you think about
it. Like it's like written like an
encyclopedia, which is just not a good
way.
uh not a good way to document code at
all. Okay, so this is better. So we
have init process group
Make sure this still runs with one
process per node.
Oh, this is
just the terminal messing with me Yeah.
well. Pretty much anything other than
this world size
one. Does that not run now?
That still runs.
Yeah, it just hangs on this. So, that's
super annoying
because how do you debug that?
I bet there's like something with me
using Cuda in
places, but like it doesn't give us a
trace back at Oh,
Yeah. So, this literally just doesn't
tell you anything.
Having a process just hang is like the
worst worst thing to freaking debug on
this.
I mean, I know I have this working on on
this version of the code, right?
There's something weird with like
forward burst forward
It's like so hard to tell because I
don't think it's getting there, right? I
think it's like failing way before.
But how the heck are you supposed to be
able to
Hell. Okay, that's interesting. That's
like
Total number of processes across all
nodes. This is supposed to be set to
not. This is like so stupidly janky. I
can't believe this is what everyone uses
for distributed
I mean, I know like stuff like deep zero
uh deep speed is zero is even
worse by like a long
shot. What the heck is
this? Invalid value for an
right? Just not picking up end
variables. Very cool.
Okay, so this is supposed to be world
size two.
this. This is probably a later error
though.
GPU.
H
noxious. Okay, so we actually that's not
me being stupid. We hit a legit bug.
So this is
here. We have this
Slightly
better. Still going to screw up. Oh, do
you have to move the policy to local
rank? You probably do, right?
That would make sense at putting it on
the wrong GPU,
right? I wish this would give me some
kind of error though. It just like
freaking hangs.
I think it just eats prince as well,
doesn't it?
software. Can I use an H use H build
puffer model generator for recycling LLM
text? Not that type of
uh not that type of RL. This is not
LLMs.
And this just drives me crazy when I
have to debug stuff blind because I
don't have enough info. It's just like
terrible
software. And like I give him a little
bit of a pass cuz like yeah, okay,
multipprocess GPU stuff. It's difficult
to like recover things from that. But
like holy hell, what are you supposed to
do when this is your feedback loop? Your
feedback loop is try a thing, nothing.
Like it's like RL with zero reward
This thing's supposed to not eat
prints
apparently. But it's literally prints on
the first line. So, I don't see how you
get around
that. Do not have to be freaking
flushing prints manually
either. I don't think that does
anything. just Yeah, that's Nothing.
here. As soon as you go to end nodes
two, it just breaks,
right? Jeep. Wait, is this how it's
supposed to be? Hang
Okay. So this is okay. I just I did not
understand how this thing
is. This is fine. Then this is expected.
Then it should
be two one should come like this.
equal. This thing still eats prints. At
least it debugs
now. Oh, wait. I think I saw Yeah, there
we are. So, there's world
size. Uh, it did still
eat. Hey, Aar. How's it going,
man? I am currently trying to get Puffer
running on 8h 800s. I had distributed
working in like a previous dev branch
and apparently I broke something.
So, we're going to see if we can get
neural MMO 3 training at like, I don't
know, three or four million steps a
second, which would then be 100 billion
steps in a day or
less. I really hate torch runs like
distributed thing. The debugging for
this is
awful. Eats prints, randomly hangs,
doesn't give you good logs.
Maybe I'm in the wrong wrong sub area,
you know? Maybe I should just build all
the freaking low-level infra for
for ML. Maybe I should just do that. I
don't
sure. But then RL doesn't get solved. So
I got to do that first.
you. This is the uh tons of puffers M.
Look at this thing. Three and a half
million steps a
second. All right, this thing took me
like three hours total to
build. The hardest part about it was
getting the assets,
frankly. You can see the episode length
going down since it's they always hit
the target. It's just how fast they do
it. All right, 30 seconds training.
Boom. Done. Just running a quick
eval. And now puffer
puffers. I mean, that's RL working just
out of the box, right?
pile me 3. This is uh this is rayb which
is using openg back end.
Yeah, but a car this is like the code
for this is very simple. This is 250
lines total including the
rendering. Like that's the step
function. It's a screen of
code. Uh and there's your observations
and that's pretty much it.
That's a thousand puffers.
Like you can do a lot of cool stuff in
this area Now,
AGI
when man when like all the bad software
and the people making bad software
decide to like get good cuz honestly the
hard stuff is not even solving the
problems. It's just fighting shitty
tools at this point.
That's the hardest thing is straight up
is just fighting shitty tooling.
Okay. So, for some reason it's assigning
both
cards. Think should be able to see all
the
Actually, I can try this with glue cuz
glue is supposed to work with this just
as a
test, right?
Ah,
okay.
So, that's
cool. Blue actually gives us
something to work with here.
Huh? That finish training? That didn't
finish training. What the heck?
types, same type and size across all
processes. Well, that's not going to be
the case.
Wait, how does this make any
sense? Oh, because wait, we take me in.
I guess technically these don't have to
have stats at the same time,
I mean, I can just log from rank one
technically.
I wish it would give me Does it give me
the full trace
back if I scroll back up?
Like that's actually would tell me quite
a bit if I have the full trace.
Okay. So
655 but it's called from 477 which is
down here. Yes. Okay.
So what we're going to do for
now since these functions do work but
they just they're not written for this.
They're like not written to be
resilient.
We'll just do this for now. I want to
get it training first and then we can
fiddle with
it. So, this will
be rank one.
If this doesn't run, it'll be because
something jank I'm doing in the policy.
Okay. Okay. So, it's definitely doing
double time here.
Uh, and it's definitely it's got two
cards
running, so it's not running it any
faster. This is with the glue back end,
though. Oh, and I have to do world
size. It's already done.
Cool. Now, if I run it with eight cards,
Man, I mean agent steps is getting the
sum, right?
why. Yeah, that doesn't make sense at
all.
cuz we're getting like at least one
update per
second and it should be 500k from each
worker. And I actually see it flickering
like each worker is at like roughly
500k. But then the sum Oh, you know why?
It's because it's not getting printed to
the main Yeah. dashboard. Okay.
Hey
Quicksautique, we're doing some
distributed shenanigans today.
8x800 H00's is
uh 200 grand worth of hardware that
because modern economics make absolutely
no sense, you can rent for less than
eight bucks an
hour. I will show you.
These guys have to be running at a loss
or
something because I have right here 88
800s to play with and it's costing me
not a lot of Okay.
Yeah, like most places have them for two
bucks each an hour. So it would be 16 an
hour. I don't know what the heck these
guys are doing. Like you run the math
and you don't break even on the hardware
cost. So they must just be selling like
extra capacity just so that they're not
What are you building, sir? I'm
currently working on
uh adding or really readding because I
had it working before and broke it, but
a distributed training for Puffer Lab,
which is our high performance
reinforcement learning
library. The goal is to be able to train
at millions of steps per second. Uh I
think actually maybe with some of the
faster environments we have, we might be
able to hit 10 million steps a second
today, which would be nuts.
It is technically
feasible. We shall
Is it possible this is just
not
printing? Yeah. I don't know if they
actually win doing that though.
is the thing, right? Like, do they
actually win when they do that or
no? Or do they just win funding and then
go
bankrupt? Oh, I think that you have to
put this. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Because it
won't get to this
call. No blockchain crypto.
Why would I do
that? I have all sorts of cool science
to advance right
here. If blockchain crypto folks want
reinforcement learning, then I have
things that I can do for that. But for
my own stuff, I mostly do the research
side.
much better than the
Russians. I don't know. Russians are
pretty cool, man. They like I hear they
like go and fight bears in the in their
free time just for the hell of
it. All right, there we go. So, that's 4
million steps per second training on
Neural MMO 3, which is kind of
ludicrous.
That's actually freaking ridiculous.
Now, the steps are not updating at the
correct rate, but yeah, 4 million step
per second neural MMO 3 training for
eight bucks an hour. So, that means that
uh holy
hell. Yeah, if that just works, can't we
like train in half a
day? Wait, who
wait? Like, hang on, hang on, hang on.
100 billion steps, right? It's a lot of
zeros. But if you divide
by 4 million steps per second and then
you divide by 300 uh 3600s per hour,
yeah, that's literally 7 hours to train
neural MMO 3. That is
obscene. Now, it does start to get a
little bit pricey if I want to leave
this on for weeks on end. But, you know,
let's say we have our new box that's
arriving tomorrow. So, like let's say
that our new box gets like, I don't
know, 25 uh 2.5 mil steps per second
because it's got six GPUs. That's still
11 hours. So, like I could leave that on
for a week and do a trillion steps of
training. Can I make it a trillion
though? You know, by 2030, we'll just
have Puffer Lib training a trillion
steps per second.
That would be worth much more than a
trillion
dollars. It context compared to a
similar real world problem
complexity. Uh it's hard like neural
MMO is way harder than the vast majority
of RLNs used in research though I will
say
um the thing is that like complexity of
problem does not necessarily correlate
to difficulty to simulate right so like
they're really easy easy learning
problems that are just hard to simulate
fast and then there are really hard
problems that are easy to simulate fast
those are the ones where you want to
throw RL like really hard problem but
easy to simulate
fast. Can't even make a good contact
physics. Yeah, I don't know, man. I've
thought about trying to like do a
physics engine, but the thing is
like, you know, the only thing that
would really get me interested in doing
like a like a really good physics sim,
like a low-level physics sim, it would
be if it weren't just like a robotics
physics sim, but if it were like some
like molecular level sim for like
physics research, advancing physics
research, or like advancing bio
research, right? Like that type of stuff
is awesome. then I then I would actually
be interested in doing like low-level
physics sim stuff.
Um like robots are cool. I'm happy to
work with people in robotics. You know,
Puffer Lib is an obvious fit for that
type of stuff. But like I think that the
most interesting use cases of RL are
actually outside of
robotics. Like humanoid robots doesn't
build like just having a ton of humanoid
robots. I don't think that gets me to
the future that I want to see as much as
like RL and a whole bunch of other
things
does. Trying to take a 3D model to a ZD
approximation. ZD
appro 3D model to
ZD. You can have 3D Sims. It's just like
it's just simulation engineering, right,
is what this is. You just need like good
systems people and like good systems
people who've built
do it after I get this working. I'd
say actually, yeah, no, let's not let's
not get distracted. Let's let's just use
this as the example end for now.
So, I also I should probably since this
is an instance, I should commit more
frequently than I normally would.
You're not excited about robots taking
over physical
jobs. Well, I think it's pretty deranged
the way that a lot of the tech CEOs talk
about that these days. like we can
automate jobs is like the most dystopian
and boring possible implementation of
this crap, right? Like we can make, you
know, we can make tech that makes like
sci-fi real, right? Like that's cool. We
can solve disease and like scarcity and
like space explor. Like these are cool
things, right?
I don't know how the hell you get up in
the morning and look at yourself in the
mirror saying, "Yep, time to go automate
some more jobs
today." That's just
lame. That's not why I get up in the
morning. I get up in the morning to do
cool research and advanced
science. What's up, Kyouong? Yo, hey,
Kyouong. If you're doing uh doing stuff
and you don't have your own hardware
yet, hyperbolic, they're a buck per 800
per hour. It's like half the price of
everything else and it takes five
minutes to set
up. We're getting tiny boxes tomorrow.
So, I'm like fiddling around with this
trying to make DDP work before we
actually have our own hardware.
How about verse vast? Less than half the
price for 800s,
man. I was using vast a fair bit and
they're good for uh 5090s and stuff, but
like if you just go
here and you do to like where is this?
Yeah, look at these H00s. A buck
80, 320,
like 640. And they're also like jank as
well. Like the machine specs are way
more different on this where they have
like way more consistently set up
machines
here. Tiny box is 4090x6. Yes. And we're
but we have two of them arriving. So we
get plus 12 GPUs. And uh back of the
envelope says that we should technically
be able to do a one trillion step neural
MMO run on that if we want to in like a
couple of
weeks. So if you got cool robotic stuff
to run, we can spot you some
compute. I actually have to go get a
screwdriver and like fix. You probably
can't hear it because I have mic
filtering, but like there are fans in
the back that are just rattling like
mad. I got to go fix on the other boxes.
So, you got to be a little careful when
buying your machines. I know all the
specs and like what to buy and what not
to now, but took a while. He bought in
August. Oh, that takes a while. I might
be back in Palo Alto by then, man. We
should meet up.
Yeah. I don't know. I might I'm going to
do like a month or two there, I
think. No idea what Berkeley's boink is.
[Music]
Okay. So, uh what next with this? I
guess we try to get uh NCCL back end
working because it's better,
You don't have to turn 3D stuff into
zerod stuff for puffer lib. You just
have to turn slow 3D stuff into fast 3D
So it works now.
It works with
If I log a stat that is shared by all
agents, do I still need to to
log.perf for each
agent or do I set log.perf? You
definitely don't set it because it's
going to get accumulated over a long uh
period of time. Um, so it's kind of up
to you, Spencer. Like you could add a
metric for instance that is uh total
dirt or whatever and then you'd have to
mess with n so that it averages out
correctly is shared. I think you would
have to add like you know numbum agents
times that metric and then increment
log.n by num agents is what you would
have to do.
Wait,
zero. No, they're they're labeled 0
through
7. Isn't that mathematically the same as
iterating through and
adding? Yeah, it's the same thing,
Spencer. So, if you have the metric and
you just want to like you can do it
either way.
Yeah, this is an NCCL error, not a me
error, I think.
Not reporting metric on multi. That's
usually how it goes.
You get me a lot of dozers running and I
will get you ludicrously fast training.
Okay.
weird. It says that setting CUD to
visible devices
thing? At least I'm not nuts. It's like
it is NCCL being weird cuz glue
works. Why is it setting them the device
to
1,800? All
right. So, this actually does set all
the ranks reasonably. Yeah.
was it. Looks like tons of people get
this crap.
Set
device local rank.
But I am I am setting the uh the device
here
now. Is it possible I
have some like jank
a cuda or something where it shouldn't
be a
Do I have to do this? I like something's
not adding up here because all these
fixes don't actually fix anything for
Okay.
this? Okay. So this is the exact error
I'm facing and it has no
replies. Exact error I'm facing has no
replies.
have? You know this is not the same
error.
pushing the model to GPU
zero. Well, two rank would be
expected. Okay, I mean I guess that does
make
sense, but like where where does it do
that?
Let me know when you get done with GPU
setup and want to talk LPS stuff. Yeah,
my bad, Aaron. Thanks. I will uh what
what time works for
you? I'm trying to fix uh multiGPU
distributed shenanigans.
Oh, you know
what? Hang
on. Try this real quick.
failing in a
net anytime until around 5:30. Sounds
good.
I will fix bug and then I will uh come
chat.
There we freaking
go. All
right. Uh we're probably going to be
ready in a second here actually.
That looks like
initial initial training
result possibly.
Does it just not give you rooe on your
own container?
Really? That's okay. We'll just do
this. Oh, we have we have to do it on um
without Adam. Does it still work with
Milan?
Aaron. Perfect.
So, uh, I'm going to go chat with Aaron
for a bit. I will be back in I don't
know how long it'll take us to get
through this hour to max. Um, and then
the plan is going to be for the rest of
today. We're going to just make
distributed training really good, as
good as we possibly can in one day. So,
um, I'm going to run this initial
benchmark on neural MMO. We're going to
fix it so that you actually log
distributed stats in a reasonable way.
and we'll do a few other general
enhancements as well. So then the hope
is that we will have like stable
training at this ridiculous speed ready
for pretty much uh for pretty much
everything. So uh thanks for tuning in
folks. I will be back later today. If
you want to support all my stuff,
puffer.ai and start the repo for free
helps me out a ton. If you want to get
involved with ultra higherf RLdev, well,
it's all open source. Join the Discord.
Thanks. And I will be back in a bit.
Bye.